platon n'est pas là tu te rends compte
aristote la tombe n'est pas la blatte on
n'est pas là il n'est pas là alors que
socrate son maître qui l'idolâtrent
s'apprête à mourir quand le gardien de
la prison vient dire que c'est l'heure
de boire le poison tout le monde est là
impossible de manquer exempt type la
femme de socrate qui sciemment
bruyamment pour tranquille sera mise
dehors
quant aux disciples ils sont tous là à
l'exception notable de xénophon le rival
de platon qui écrira aussi sur socrate
mais xénophon lui a une bonne excuse il
est en campagne militaire en asie
et puis il manque aussi aristide de
cyrène qui fondera l'hédonisme parce
qu'il est comment dire
en voyage d'affaires
[Musique]
ap
mais surtout platon n'est pas là platon
l'héritier surdoué d'une famille dont on
dit qu'elle est la plus riche et la plus
puissante politiquement à athènes sept
héritiers qui a renoncé dans un premier
temps un destin tout tracé qui l'aurait
mené au pouvoir puis dans un second
temps à ses rêves d'artiste il a renoncé
à tous pourquoi poursuivre 1/2 clochard
qui est une réputation d' escroc platon
à renoncer à tout pour se consacrer à
socrate
mais au moment le plus important de la
ville selon m il est absent et
rencontrer stocks
d'après la version officielle la tombe
est elle malade
bref on n'a pas retrouvé le certificat
médical 1
la vérité est beaucoup plus compliqué la
vérité c'est que si platon avait été
présent avec tous les autres auprès de
ceux crac
nous n'aurions peut-être jamais entendu
parler ni de ce krach ni de plaques
mettez vous à la place de plateaux
l'homme grâce auquel vous avez trouvé le
sens de votre vie un homme que vous
vénérez plus que tout cet homme si
important pour vous qui est plus qu'un
père cet homme a été condamné à mort il
vous l'avait abandonnée dans ses
derniers instants
l'absence de platon c'est la clé pour
comprendre le mystère socrates
rendez vous compte ce kraft c'est un
fils d'ouvrier au physique repoussant à
la réputation exécrable à athènes et qui
n'a rien écrit
c'est cet homme là dont le nom est
presque devenu synonyme de philosophie
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé il
faut revenir aux origines
je vais donc vous raconter socrates
comme vous le connaissez pas je vais
notamment vous révéler les raisons
cachées de la mauvaise réputation du
père de la philosophie les secrets
maquillés par les disciples les ressorts
du complot qui a abouti à la
condamnation à mort de socrate
et puis surtout vous comprendrez à la
fin de la vidéo
la raison de l'absence inexplicable de
plateaux et les conséquences d'un
incroyable qu'elle aura dans l'histoire
de la philosophie la fin de cette vidéo
vous ne devez plus de crainte de la même
manière et votre regard sur la
philosophie aura changé je fus romain je
suis avec mon fidèle aristote avec h et
vous êtes sur mille idées de culture
générale pour être tenir autrement ça
fait plusieurs mois qu'on n'a pas fait
une vidéo
j'ai ramené le prompteur tu l'a même pas
reconnu taha boyer
[Musique]
je vais commencer par vous raconter les
origines étonnante de ce crash
mais je dois d'abord vous dire
rapidement trois petites choses
ils vont vous intéresser tout d'abord je
vous propose de télécharger ma synthèse
des 100 meilleures idées philosophiques
que vous soyez étudiant ou pas c'est un
moyen efficace de découvrir facilement
ou de revoir rapidement les idées
majeures de l'histoire de la pensée bien
sûr celle de feu crac la deuxième petite
chose que j'ai à vous dire c'est que je
compte faire à d'autres vidéos sur les
vies des plus grands philosophes
j'ai déjà commencé pour platon aristote
voltaire et sartre donc
abonnez-vous à la chaîne youtube si ça
vous intéresse et puis dites moi dans
les commentaires quels sont les
philosophes dont vous aimeriez découvrir
la vie enfin dernière précision dans ses
vidéos je vais uniquement vous raconter
la vie de ce krach en me focalisant sur
les aspects méconnus
donc si vous voulez plus de détails ou
si vous vous intéressez aux idées de ce
crash
je vous ai mis tout le nécessaire dans
la description de la vidéo
vous y trouverez aussi mes sources et
j'ai également ajouté le minutage de la
vidéo
donc n'hésitez pas à la regarder en
plusieurs fois si vous préférez voilà
c'est bon je peux maintenant vous
raconter mes origines étonnante de
socrate
vous savez pourquoi les disciples en
parle si peu parce que c'est la légende
qu'ils veulent vous servir
[Musique]
à
le mystère se kraft commence avec ses
origines ses disciples n'en parle pas
beaucoup
il essaie peut être même de les cacher
car les adversaires de ce cra tu
utilises ses origines contre lui pour le
discréditer
ils répondent par exemple la rumeur
qu'il est un fils d'esclave
c'est à dire qu'il ne serait pas un vrai
citoyen atteignant alors cette rumeur
est fausse
mais quel est le problème avec les
origines de socrate
le problème c'est que secrète est un
fils d'ouvrier qui évoluent dans un
milieu aristocratique et cela dans une
société où la valeur des ancêtres
rejaillit sur les bêtises à athènes être
le fils de quelqu'un suffit d être
quelqu'un a exercé un ascendant sociale
bien sûr c'est toujours le cas dans les
sociétés occidentales mais dans une
moindre mesure par rapport à l'antiquité
grecque par exemple la famille de platon
et si prestigieuse qui ne révèle pas son
nom lors des compétitions de lutte on le
laisse tranquille
dans le détail cependant le rapport
entre classes sociales est paradoxal à
athènes d'un côté ce n'est pas un
système de castes la cité ouverte tout
le monde se côtoient et se fréquente
plutôt librement
mais de l'autre les aristocrates font
preuve d'un véritable mépris de classe à
l'égard du peuple athénien or ce crac
lui n'est le fils de personne il
néanmoins 470 de l'union d'une sage
femme fait n'arrête et d'un ouvrier
sculpteur sofronis qu ses origines sont
donc très modeste ou ne peut
probablement pas faire plus modeste dans
l'athènes de l'époque sage femme c'était
un métier subalternes et la plupart des
accoucheuses étaient des esclaves
la rumeur selon laquelle socrates était
un esclave vient peut-être de là quant à
son père s'offre nysc ce n'était pas
vraiment un artisan mais un ouvrier son
talent qui sculptait grossièrement le
marbre des carrières à côté desquels
vivait la famille en clair à la famille
vit
dans la pauvreté le père vont quelques
statuettes par ci par là et la mère ne
tire pas grand chose de ses services du
coup ce krach n'aura pas le choix il
exercera le même métier que son père il
sculptera le marbre pour survivre il n'a
tout simplement pas les moyens de
s'adonner à la philosophie n'a pas les
moyens dont la travailler il n'a pas les
moyens de suivre des cours et n'a pas
non plus les moyens de voyager pour
s'initier aux sagesses qui ont influencé
la philosophie de la grèce antique
notamment la sagesse égyptienne je
caricature mais à l'époque la
philosophie c'est un peu un truc
d'enfant gâté qu'il faut avoir le frigo
plein et être blasé de la richesse et de
la loire qui n'a pas la conquérir pour
valoriser la réflexion des intéressés
c'est pour ça que beaucoup de
philosophes sont des aristocrates ou des
fils d'homme d'affaires prospère et un
destin à la platon ou l'héritier renonce
à ses privilèges pour se consacrer à la
sagesse n'est en réalité pas si
exceptionnel tout ça pour dire que ce
graphe ne naît pas avec les bonnes
cartes mais il ya quand même des choses
que le père de la philosophie doit à ses
origines
il n'avait ni nom ni argent ni
compétences remarquables
seulement on mérite toujours de quelque
chose si on n'est pas orphelin alors les
disciples veulent vous faire croire que
leur maître est un génie parachuté par
les dieux
un homme dit vincent racines terrestre
et peut-être ont-ils pensé à prétendre
comme la tradition le fera pour platon
tant d'autres personnages se trace n'a
pas de père ils veulent vous faire
croire que le magnétisme de leur maître
est un don du ciel
la réalité c'est que socrate fils de son
père parce qu'il a grandi auprès de lui
sofronis qu est certes un nouveau
médiocre mais il est exceptionnellement
sympathique
il est charismatique il est affable il
connaît tout le monde parle avec tout le
monde
sa présence est toujours agréable aux
autres ouvriers d'un berceau aristote le
père de se gratter charismatique et
socrate ou aussi et charismatique
peut-être un lien ans
[Musique]
à l'évidence ce crac tirs 6 grandes
qualités humaines de son père et il les
cultivent râle de la même manière comme
son père il côtoie les boutiques
il fréquente les différents artisans de
forgeron le cordonnier le potier ou
encore les tailleurs de pierre ainsi que
leurs ouvriers il est à l'aise dans ce
milieu
au point qu'il y nouer des amitiés
durables or les disciples élevé dans les
milieux les plus privilégiés d'athènes
auront honte de ses fréquentations
populaire par exemple il minimiseront
l'affection de socrate pour simuler le
savetier un artisan fière et
indépendante qui a refusé le mécénat de
périclès
mais plus fondamentalement les disciples
ne veulent pas voir que leurs maîtres
cet homme toujours bien entouré qui
scelle ses interlocuteurs de questions
dans les rues bancaire ils ne veulent
pas voir que cet homme celle adolescent
sociable qui les mutations de son père
parcourait les boutiques pour converser
avec les hommes simples et pragmatiques
de sa condition socrates fera ce qu'il a
toujours fait
il n'est pas un as est court mais dit
dans une grotte il n'est pas fait pour
la solitude
il est comme un poisson dans l'eau parmi
les hommes quel qu'il soit on parle de
la maïeutique sa méthode pour faire
accoucher les esprits en référence à sa
mère la coucheuse fennecs mais c'est une
image anecdotique à la vérité c'est la
gouaille populaire de son père qui est à
l'oeuvre
quand le philosophe accostent les
passants et les interroge sans politesse
sur un pied d'égalité sans le moindre
égard pour leur statut
après socrates n'a pas renié ses
origines au contraire il en était plutôt
fier il était sensible à la noblesse de
l'artisanat et y est resté dans la
misère toute sa vie parce qu'il
considérait que l'abondance détournent
de la vertu ce sont les disciples qui
ont renié par mépris de classe les
origines du maître et encore ce n'est
pas la seule chose qui nous ont caché
[Musique]
imaginez la scène on est en 424 avant
jésus-christ socrates à 46 ans il vient
de rentrer de la bataille de des lions
que les athéniens perdu et il assiste à
la représentation d'une comédie qui le
met en scène les nuées d'aristophane
exténué par le voyage est abattu par la
défaite non aristote bas alors je suis
obligé de reprendre
donc je disais exténué par le voyage est
abattu par la défaite
il reçoit le coup de grâce les moqueries
du public parce qu'à reste fall n'est
pas tendre avec lui la pièce raconte
l'histoire d'un père accablé de dettes
qui doit rendre des comptes à la justice
et qu'est ce qu'il fait pour se tirer
d'affaires il envoie son fils à prendre
des armes à des intellectuels auprès de
socrate comme ça il y persuadera les
juges et il évitera de payer ses
créanciers et il n'y a aucun doute que
ça va marcher car on dit de ce krach
qu'il est capable de faire passer pour
onet la cause la plus crapuleuse et oui
on parle bien de socrate celui dont on
dit qu'il est le père de la philosophie
mais alors c'est quoi cette histoire je
voulais déjà dit à athènes la réputation
de socrate et excécrable alors c'est sûr
qu'il est célèbre puisqu'il est un
personnage de comédie mais il est
célèbre comme escrocs raconte il apprend
à échapper à la justice
or c'est à ce type de compétence entre
guillemets qu'on reconnaît les sophistes
mais il rappelle si vous ne savez pas à
qui étaient les pistes c'était d'être
professeur de rhétorique itinérant qui
sont arrivés à athènes grosso modo à
l'époque de socrate et qui sont passés à
la postérité comme des intellectuels qui
n'en avait rien à faire de la vérité
tout ce qui comptait pour eux
presles image biaisée y en a aujourd'hui
c'était gagné le débat et gagner de
l'argent
voilà j'ai fait simple et rapide donc si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
sophistes je vous recommande ma vidéo
intitulée cinq raisons de réhabiliter
les six que vous pouvez voir soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite soit sur celui qui est
dans la description de la vidéo
alors je vous conseille de regarder ma
vidéo sur les sophistes plus tard parce
que j'ai encore beaucoup de choses
étonnantes à vous révéler sur socrate
je reviens donc à lui le mini rappelle
été remis dans la pièce d'aristophane
dont ce crabe les spectateurs à son
retour de la guerre
son personnage est un sophiste donc il
faut croire que les athéniens le
prennent pour un sophiste c'est d'autant
plus probable
cariste aux fans n'est pas le seul à
considérer socrates comme un sophiste
pour android dont un historien du ivème
siècle avant jésus-christ qui est donc
très proche des événements pour cet
historien socrates est mort en martyr de
la sophistique mais martyrs au sens
d'apôtres de grand prêtre de la
sophistique c'est à dire que ce crâne
était d'après cet historien le sophiste
par excellence aux trotteurs qui donne
la même version et signe le plus
brillant orateur avec des mots stèle du
ivème siècle avant jésus-christ qui est
seulement neuf ans après la mort de
socrate et bien cet auteur appelle le
philosophe socrate le sophiste et je
pourrais vous citer encore d'autres
auteurs qui arrange ce cap
parmi les sophistes mais la devise de
militer de culture générale c'est pas de
prise de tête
donc je m'arrête là alors j'imagine
votre réaction
non mais sur crac c'est l'adversaire des
sophistes il les dénonce comme de faux
philosophe
oui moi aussi j'ai appris ça mais encore
une fois il s'agit de la légende
la version écrite est propagée par les
disciples
pour retrouver la vérité il faut prendre
en considération deux choses la première
c'est que les sophistes avait une grande
influence dans la tête de ceux kraft et
donc rares sont les intellectuels ou les
auteurs qui n'ont pas appris à leurs
côtés c'est d'autant plus probable que
les sophistes et former ce crac que leur
activité intellectuelle était public
contrairement aux philosophes qui vivait
détacher de la cité autrement dit il
suffisait aux jeunes socrates qui en
plus était habile dans les relations
sociales et lui suffisait de s'immiscer
dans les discussions dans les débats
dans les banquets mondain et de se faire
bien voir des professeurs jusqu'à
devenir un de leurs habitudes et ainsi
lui qui n'avait pas le sou pouvait
développer sa compétence intellectuelle
sans rien payer
par exemple il rencontre protagoras le
sophiste star d'athènes
chez le riche callas il a 26 ans et
lit-on sur le champ et les longues assez
probable que ce grâce tu sois mis à la
philosophie grâce aux sophistes puis
qu'il en soit devenu un parce que
c'était pour lui le seul moyen possible
de se former
plus fondamentalement la distinction
entre le philosophe et le sophisme
n'était pas aussi marquée qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
pour nous le philosophe c'est un
individu qui recherche la vérité et le
sophiste un menteur
mais à l'époque les philosophes et les
sophistes était en contact permanent il
échangé des idées des méthodes et des
techniques on puise surtout des
sophistes se disait philosophes et des
philosophes abete aussi une activité de
ce fils en clair la frontière était très
flou parmi les maîtres connu de ceux
kraft certains comme arc et aloses 2000
est était de la première génération de
philosophes qui ont émigré à athènes
d'autres étaient des sophistes des
professeurs qui vont dès lors sa poire
mais encore une fois toutes ces
personnes évoluer dans un même
lieu intellectuel ce n'est donc pas
étonnant qu'on retrouve si on souscrit
pas légende l'influencent des sophistes
dans la pensée de ce crash
certains sophistes comme prodi cost
avait déjà popularisé la culture de la
définition et pour ce qui est de la
dialectique de ce crash est bien là
ressemble beaucoup au traditionnel
discours double des sophistes après
socrates et ses disciples se sont
appropriés et ont donné une autre
dimension à ces techniques philosophique
mais ils ne les ont probablement pas
inventé donc voilà pour la première
chose à prendre en compte
socrates a probablement été formés par
les sophistes seconde chose à prendre en
compte rapprocher de la vérité
l'âge de ce crash quand platon rencontre
sera tu le mettras 60 ans et il ne lui
reste plus que dix ans à vivre autrement
dit platon ne connaît que le vieux
socrates
il ne connaît pas le jeune socrates
celui qui aristophane dépeint comme un
escroc notoire
celui qu'on dit emporté et provocateur
ou point qu'on en fera un précurseur des
cyniques ces philosophes qui érigeront
le scandale en mode de vie l'adversaire
des sophistes celui qui les dénoncent
c'est donc plutôt le vieux socrates du
coup l'hypothèse qu'on peut faire c'est
que ce crabe soit en réalité un renégat
de la sophistique socrates seraient
converties sur le tard à ce qu'il
conçoit comme la philosophie authentique
et il aurait renié son passé de
sophistes ou plutôt ce serait si
disciples qui aurait gommé le passé de
sophistes de leurs maîtres et renier
l'héritage des sophistes dans
l'enseignement socratique la légende a
fait de ce crash
l'adversaire des sophistes mais il en
est plutôt le plus célèbre élèves
certaines rumeurs courraient d'ailleurs
sur les motifs de sa conversion d'après
certains qui forcément ne tenait pas ce
crade dans leur coeur
c'est parce que sa carrière de ce fils
était un échec commercial qu'il aurait
pris une autre voie
bon ça ressemble plus à innover
moeurs malveillante mais ça confirme
l'hypothèse probable d'une conversion
tardive à la philosophie tel qu il
n'entendra en tout cas la question de
l'argent sera un contentieux entre
socrates et les sophistes le philosophe
reproche aux sophistes de monétiser leur
savoir et donc d'avoir en vue le profit
plutôt qu'une finalité supérieur plus
d'un bleu il conseille aux jeunes gens
de ne pas se faire avoir de suivre
plutôt des maîtres qui transmettent
gratuitement leur sagesse comme
libération
bon d'accord mais là je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de me demander d'où part le
tilt de quoi vite il lui est ce qu'il
vit de philosophie et d'eau fraîche
alors socrates ne travaille pas il
laisse sa femme et ses trois enfants
dans la misère mais comment s'en sort-il
pour les nécessités matérielles de
l'existence
eh bien il n'a pas ou plutôt il n'a plus
besoin de faire le sophiste parce qu'il
est entretenue comme ses disciples son
richissime il vite à leurs frais
son principal mécène et son camarade
d'enfance criton qui est une sorte de
self made men athénien il mettra même sa
fortune engage tous faire évader secrète
de prison après le procès alors certes
socrates vie quand même petitement mais
pour être cohérent avec son discours il
fallait soit qu'ils travaillaient côté
soit qu'ils vivent comme un clochard en
renonçant totalement à l'argent mais non
lui se faisait entretenir et il allait
dans les meilleures banques 1 et c'est
la même chose pour platon comme je l'aï
déjà dit dans ma vidéo sur les sophistes
taton était l'héritier de la famille la
plus riche date m l'argent n'a donc
jamais été un souci pour lui à tel point
qu'une rémunération n'aurait une stricte
e mans aucun intérêt d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être platon le disciple qui n'a pas
connu ce 4e sophistes et qui a vécu hors
de la réalité économique c'est peut-être
bien lui qui a radicalisé la critique du
maître landes contre les sophistes en
conclusion socrates le défenseur de la
philosophie authentique de la vérité et
de la justice face aux vilains sophistes
c'est une vision très déformée de la
réalité
c'est la légende des disciples après ils
ne sont pas les seules frappes briques
acteurs du socrates qu'on connaît la
biographie de philosophe a aussi été
adapté ou le tabou de la modernité
c'est le cas notamment de sa vie
sentimentale aujourd'hui on dirait que
ce raté d'un pédophile
[Musique]
à
s'il ya bien une légende qui semble
correspondre à la réalité c'est celle
sur la laideur de socrate on le compare
à un silène la créature mythologique
associé à l'ivresse une sorte de
croisement entre un homme rustre et un
taureau socrates a de grosses lèvres une
barbe à l'implantation sauvage 1 et
camus donc pas grec des narines dilatées
des yeux saillants et la fronde
proéminent pour les grecs qui sacralise
la beauté physique
c'est un choc pour eux qui ont
l'habitude de déduire la personnalité
d'un homme de ses traits physiques
ce krach ne peut être que des lille et
débauché ils interprètent une
exhortation les yeux sortent de leur
orbite comme le signe d'un mélange
d'intelligence et de sensualité aussi
pour les chiens
d'autres commentateurs de la physionomie
de ce crac estime que son caractère
sauvage révèle plus précisément un goût
pour les prostituées effectivement c'est
précis ce qui est certain c'est qu'en
plus de ne pas avoir été gâté par la
nature
le philosophe n'arrange pas les choses
il se néglige physiquement un degré qui
justifierait l'exclusion des gymnases
gymnase
qu'est ce qu'un philosophe et dans les
gymnases secrète n'y va pas pour
s'entraîner mais pour mater comme pas
mal des philosophes de son époque
il a un goût prononcé pour les petits
garçons disons les pré adolescents alors
dans la grèce antique la relation
homosexuelle prétendument éducative
entre un homme adulte les races et un
jeune garçon
les roumaines cette relation était une
institution
c'était très répandue dans les milieux
aristocratiques artistiques et
philosophiques
il y avait même une tradition de la
poésie pédérastique où les restes
compose pour les romains et dans les
écoles philosophiques la pédérastie se
transmet tel de m en disciple socrates
aurait par exemple été initiés à la mort
y en même temps qu'à la philosophie par
ces premiers mètres
arqués la hausse de miley seulement pour
certains témoins des auteurs de l'époque
la relation spéciale m disciples et la
transmission du savoir
c'était un peu un prétexte pour laisser
s'exprimer derrière un ascétisme kassab
un instinct de prédateur
plutarque écrit par exemple dans
érotique hausse il met en avant l'amitié
la vertu il se couvre de poussière dans
l'arène prend des bains froids fronce
les sourcils à l'extérieur il se donne
l'air d'un philosophe et d'un sage cause
de la loi
puis la nuit quand où reposent tous et
la cueillette en l'absence du gardien le
terrain de chasse des philosophes ce
sont les palets str les lieux publics
qui certes à l'entraînement des jeunes
gens
les rapports ont généralement lieu dans
les salles sombres qui entourent
l'espace
l'exercice socrates est apparemment un
pédéraste très actif il est fasciné par
la sensualité des corps des lutteurs
juvénile qui s'exerce dans les pales est
il tombe par exemple amoureux de charme
id l'oncle de platon un très beau garçon
fragile et influençable de 10 13 ans qui
l'avait déjà remarqué plusieurs années
auparavant
platon restera public à propos de cette
relation secrète aura également une
relation avec le jeune buteur vedette
l'isis alors âgée de 14 ans mais surtout
ce crac multiplie les amants parmi ses
disciples qui sont sous son charme
on peut citer notamment phèdre et idem
agathon critot bull auto lycos à nistos
et le fameux alcibiade l'attrait que le
maître exerce sur ses disciples et elke
antisthène le futur fondateur de l'école
cynique n'hésite pas à faire chaque jour
les 18 km du trajet aller retour du
pirée socrates n'a pas vraiment de
limites car il a même une relation avec
critot bull
le fils de son mécène criton qui on peut
le comprendre ne voit pas ça d'un très
bon oeil la dimension pédérastique de
l'enseignement socratique et notw à
athènes les jeunes gens simples que
apprendre la sagesse auprès du
philosophe il faut passer sous le
manteau le fameux manteau salle et
défraîchie de socrate qu'il porte
été comme hiver et qui sert donc aussi
aux ébats avec les rebelles
on raconte que le cours particuliers
dérape parfois et il n'est pas rare
qu'on surprennent le mettre à épier de
jeunes garçons à en croire les
témoignages
socrates était donc aussi un pervers
alors encore une fois je sais bien comme
je l'aï déjà dit que la pédérastie était
une institution dans la grèce antique
seulement la manière dont les
philosophes et en particulier ceux crac
la pratique elle en se servant de leur
autorité morale et de leur intelligence
cette manière indigne et déjà des
témoins de l'époque et des historiens
qui nie
n'y aurait pas la place de la pédérastie
dans la société athénien je vous ai par
exemple citer la réprobation de plus
tard qu un penseur majeur de la
romantique qui se situe pourtant
philosophiquement parlant dans la
filiation de socrate et de plateaux pour
être encore plus précis
moi je ne place pas dans une posture
morale
je ne dis pas à la secrète était un
pervers pédophile
non ce que je veux c'est souligner le
grand contraste entre d'une part l'image
que nous avons de ce krach images des
façonné par les disciples puis filtrée
par les tabous de la modernité et
d'autres pas la réalité historique
d'après les biographies d'après les
témoignages
socrates n'était pas le sage qu'on peut
imaginer
lemaitre qui domine ses patients l'homme
exclusivement épris de vérité
bien sûr il y a là aussi comme pour le
conflit avec les sophistes une question
d'âge
on peut raisonnablement penser que la
passion pédérastique de socrate affaibli
avec les années et c'est peut-être même
du silence du corps qui a émergé la
théorie socratique d'un amour noble que
platon présente dans le banquet
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas de ce que je
lui si platon qui est un disciple tardif
de ce gratte est passé lui aussi sous le
manteau mais comme il approchait la
vingtaine
il était peut-être trop vieux au bout de
six mètres
autre élément révélateur de l'évolution
de socrate il a pris femme comme on dit
assez tard c'est dans sa 50ème qu'il a
épousée exempt type une athénienne de
bonne famille qu'on prétend ligne et à
périclès alors on ne sait pas trop
pourquoi il a décidé de se marier
certains font l'hypothèse que c'est par
civisme pour combler le vide
démographique creusé par la guerre du
péloponnèse
en tout cas il n'y a pas eu de coup de
foudre ni de jeu de séduction comme dans
les gymnases avec les lutteurs
prépubères le secrète des 20 dernières
années
celui qui s'apprête à connaître platon
n'est plus le même socrates
il est loin des excès de sa jeunesse il
s'est écarté des sophistes
il ne poursuit probablement plus les
jeunes garçons de ses assiduités
seulement les gens n'oublient pas comme
ça on raconte que ce krach a changé
lorsqu'il s'est vu tourner en dérision
en sophistes escroc dans la pièce
d'aristophane on dit que c'est à ce
moment qu'il a embrassé son destin sa
mission philosophique
seulement on ne se refait pas une
virginité comme ça et athènes a la
mémoire longue
on n'efface pas le passé
[Musique]
or
maintenant on est en 323 avant
jésus-christ soit 76 ans après la mort
de socrate aristote non pas toi
le disciple de socrate aristote fui
athènes parce qu'il se sent menacé il
part avec sa famille à challes 6 une île
à 80 kilomètres d'athènes et il dit je
ne laisserai pas les athéniens commettre
un second crime contre la philosophie
le premier crime c'est la condamnation à
mort ils se grattent 76 ans après
aristote qui pensent encore l'injustice
est encore présente dans son esprit et
sa remarque est d'autant plus approprié
que ce qui lui arrive ressemble à ce qui
était arrivé à socrate
c'est un complot du même ordre qui se
trame revenons 76 ans en arrière
nous sommes dans 399 avant jésus-christ
en février un jeune poète du nombre de
mails et os remettent alarcon 3 une
plainte contre socrates
socrates est coupable de ne pas croire
au dieu reconnus par l'état et
d'introduire de nouvelles divinités
il est en outre coupables de corrompre
les jeunes jambes peine la mort c'est
l'accusation tipi qui comporte contre
ceux dont on veut se débarrasser
38 ans plus tôt un hexagone le tout
premier philosophe à s'établir à athènes
a été condamné à mort pour inquiéter
après quoi il s'est exilé grâce à l'aide
de périclès à 600 km de là 76 ans après
le procès de ce pape
l'histoire se répète avec aristote lui
aussi visé pour inquiéter et qui choisit
la même solution cana hexagone en 399
secrète lui non plus n'est pas en odeur
de sainteté à athènes
et il ya plusieurs raisons à cela il y a
tout d'abord sa vie quotidienne
socrates s'est quand même un genre de
clochards qui harcèlent les gens dans
les rues qui leur parlent sans politesse
sans respect pour leur statut
est-il et rabaisse en leur montrant
qu'ils ne savent rien je caricature un
peu mais la maïeutique dans les rues
d'athènes
c'est ça pardon pour ma vulgarité mais
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ce
krach fait chier les gens notamment les
bourgeois qui n'ont rien demandé
et parmi lesquels il se fait de
véritables ennemis ça c'est pour la
forme mais il ya le fond aussi les idées
de socrate dérange il critique la
démocratie alors qu'elle vient d'être
rétabli son fameux démons personnels
heurte le religieusement correct
ils remettent en cause les vertus
traditionnelles et puis son détachement
à l'égard de la politique passe pour de
l'égoïsme l'attitude et les idées de
ceux crac en fonte on cible facile dans
le contexte politique tendu de l'après
guerre du péloponnèse
une guerre qui a duré 28 ans la masse
bourgeoise n'en a rien à faire de
l'enseignement du secret de sa
dialectique et de sa morale ce qu'elle
veut c'est pouvoir de nouveau faire du
business tranquillement s'enrichir de
manière très visible sans troubles
politiques
or elle pense que le philosophe menace
cette ambition à en croire platon
socrate a bien conscience qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup de fans à athènes à la fin du
gorille à socrate s'imaginent qu'on le
condamne à mort et il se défend en se
comparant à un médecin condamné par des
enfants that agnan je serai jugé comme
le serait un médecin accusé devant des
enfants par une cuisinière enfants je
n'ai fait tout cela que pour vous
conservez la santé la seconde partie de
l'accusation
il est en outre coupables de corrompre
les jeunes gens cette partie fait
référence au destin funeste 2 certains
disciples de socrate qui était du parti
oligarchique
ce sont surtout les trahisons
d'alcibiade et de christiane deux
aristocrates brillant donc mais débauche
et sans scrupules prêts à tout faire
pour avancer leurs propres intérêts ce
sont surtout ces deux destins qui sont
encore dans toutes les têtes et qui
entachent la réputation déjà bien
mauvaise de socrate
mais bon il faut se mettre un peu à la
place des athéniens si des disciples
sont capables de tels actes qu'est ce
que ça dit sur l'enseignement éthique du
maître alors ce krach dira simplement
qu'il a échoué à former cette diable
mais la suspicion des athéniens n'y pas
stupide dans l'absolu tout comme la
culpabilité du fils rejaillir sur le
père celle du disciple peut rejaillir
sur le m après ce crash a eu beaucoup de
disciples dans l'élite athénienne et des
deux côtés dans le parti oligarchique
mais aussi dans le parti démocratique
l'accusation prend ce qu'il arrange
parce que son but n'est pas de juger
socrates mais de s'en débarrasser en
effet le procès a tout d'un complot
plusieurs personnes se sont entendus
secrètement pour se débarrasser de ce
crash dans l'intérêt de la bourgeoisie
atteignait mais les tos le jeune poète
qui a déposé la plainte est un
accusateur de paille
l'homme qui tire les ficelles s'appelle
à nistos c'est un tanneur qui a fait
fortune et qui milite pour le retour à
une démocratie tempéré un bon régime
pour le business
un procès représente plusieurs risques
pour lui en termes de temps passé de
réputation et puis d'argent qu'un échec
donc ils sous-traitent l'accusation à
deux hommes médiocre celui qui prend sur
lui il risque de l'accusation sceller
les taux ce que j'ai déjà évoqué c'est
un poète raté de 30 ans qui donne
surtout dans la poésie érotique et dont
les oeuvres sont si mauvaises qu'elles
sont sifflés et que le nom même de mails
et os est devenu une insulte
il faut ajouter que comme beaucoup de
poètes à l'époque il est jaime
l'autorité morale des philosophes celui
qui dans le complot va instruire la
faire c'est à dire porter la parole de
l'accusation c'est l'orateur à gages
l'ico cet homme en veut à socrate pour
la mort de son fils prodige auto lycos
autrefois célébré dans les milieux les
plus élitistes de la cité pour son
exceptionnelle beauté et ses exploits
sportifs se fit sans laquelle ils
avaient placé de grands espoirs
ce fils dont il était dépendant pour son
ascension sociale a été tué par les 30
tirs en gouvernements oligarchiques qui
a dirigé à thème pendant au moins d'un
an
- 404 alors comme son fils a été victime
de ce gouvernement
il voudra se venger de toutes personnes
liées de près ou de loin à
l'établissement de latéral or je voulais
dit plusieurs des têtes de proue du
régime étaient des disciples de ce kraft
dont clinique on considère que le
philosophe est en partie responsable de
l'assassinât de son fils
il a également une raison plus directe
d'accepter le deal des noces c'est qu'il
est lui même soupçonné de trahison pour
lever les soupçons il doit donc donner
les gages de son allégeance à la
démocratie donc les deux hommes de
paille mais les tos qui porte
l'accusation
elie konki va porter la parole de
ces deux hommes ont tous deux à la fois
un intérêt immédiat dans le complot et
un ressentiment à l'encontre de socrate
c'est le cocktail parfait c'est aussi le
cas du cerveau du complot à nistos il ya
d'abord un conflit personnel avec
socrate il lui reproche d'avoir dit à
son fils qu'il était trop intelligent
pour reprendre la ferme paternelle et
que s'il le faisait il sombrerait dans
l'alcoolisme
il n'en fallait pas plus pour le
convaincre de la dangerosité du
philosophe qui dresse et les fils contre
les pères mais au delà du conflit
personnel
le riche industriel est l'antithèse
sociologique de socrate il est riche
influent volontaire et pragmatique quand
le philosophe et pauvres indifférent
sceptiques et passifs après il n'ya
probablement personne qui tire les
ficelles d'encore plus loin derrière à
nistos parce que cet homme d'affaires
est à lui seul très influent dans la
démocratie athénienne où ils achètent
magistrat les orateurs voir des juges
c'est sûr que se débarrasser de socrate
arrangera à bien des gens mais à nistos
le fait pour lui parce qu'il est
convaincu que c'est la bonne chose à
faire maintenant que j'ai décrite les
ressorts immédiat du complot je dois
préciser quelques nuances
la première c'est que le projet était en
réalité plutôt modérée à nistos qui
était un démocrate convaincu se serait
satisfait de l'exil de socrate et c'est
probablement le scénario qu'il imaginait
parce qu il était de coutume dans les
procès de l'époque
en cas de condamnation de choisir la
fonction proposée par l'accusé
en clair si secrète avait proposé de
partir date m
la solution aurait probablement été
retenu et il aurait été sauvée seulement
ça ne s'est pas passé comme ça et on
arrive à la seconde une anse secrète a
multiplié les provocations son attitude
relève presque de l'auto sabotage il n'a
pas préparé son discours il a même
refusé celui écrit pour lui par lysias
qui était le meilleur avocat athénien de
l'époque
il parle très simplement aux jurés en
ignorant les attendus de l'éloquence
judiciaire et il ne donne aucun gage de
bonne volonté
enfin il use de sa méthode habituelle
qui al'effet habituel sur une partie de
l'audience ces questions énerve
et pourtant malgré son habitude il n'est
condamné qu'à une faible majorité sur
les 501 jurés du tribunal
281 le déclare coupable et 220 la quitte
ce qui fait en pourcentage un rapport 56
à en juger par ce résultat le complot a
failli échouer et on peut imaginer
qu'avec un peu de bonne volonté secrète
aurait gagné le procès à nistos savait
que l'accusation était fragile c'est
pour ça qu'il est passé par deux hommes
de paille mais l'authenticité de ce
krach lui a facilité la tâche
le philosophe
j'ai coupable il ne reste plus qu'à
déterminer la sanction
et comme je voulais dire à ce stade il
peut encore se sauver en proposant une
peine raisonnable
l'exil comme un axe d'accord avant lui
comme aristote après lui il peut
terminer sa vie tranquille loin
d'athènes
c'est mal le connaître au lieu de saisir
sa chance ils commettent une dernière
provocation comme sentence il propose
une récompense
qu'est-ce qui peut convenir à un
bienfaiteur pauvres qui a besoin de
loisirs pour vous exhorter il n'est rien
athéniens qui conviennent mieux à un tel
homme que d'être nourris au prytanée
être nourri au prytanée
c'était la récompense traditionnelle des
plus grands bienfaiteurs d'athènes
autrement dit socrate insulte les jurés
ce qui relève du suicide
quand la peine proposée par l'accusation
et la peine de mort radicalisé par cette
dernière provocation
les jurés vote la peine de mort à une
large majorité 361 voix contre 140 soit
72%
le complot danito ça finalement réussi
ou au delà de ses espérances
une accusation très fragile sans faits
précis à reprocher à l'acte et sans
preuve matérielle avec le concours de
deux hommes médiocre contre un
philosophe éloquent détacher des partis
politiques et qui bénéficie de soutiens
dans l'élite athénienne malgré toutes
ces forces contraires à une noce a
réussi à faire condamner à mort
l'individu dont il voulait se
débarrasser c'est tout simplement parce
que secrète n'a pas voulu jouer le jeu
le complot a réussi grâce à la
complicité de la victime
mais le plus important est encore à
venir
[Musique]
bah
comment platon peut-il être absent
comment peut-on être absent à la mort de
l'homme auxquels on va consacrer son
oeuvre
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas plutôt
poser la question dans l'autre sens
pourquoi consacré son oeuvre à l'homme
qu'on n'a pas jugé bon d'accompagner à
la mort paradoxalement c'est platon 8
même qui racontera dans le phédon sans
avoir été le témoin direct des scènes la
dernière journée et les dernières
confidente de socrate et il a bien fait
son travail parce que la valeur
historique du récit n'a pas été remise
en cause
en réalité il ne s'est rien passé
d'exceptionnel la peine a été exécuté
comme prévu le gardien chef a appartenu
le poison se gratte la bulle sans
attendre il a ensuite marché dans la
cellule jusqu'à sentir une pesanteur
dans les jambes c'est alors allongé pour
laisser agir le poison jusqu'où peut
d'ailleurs l'événement est passé quasi
inaperçu dans la cité des disciples ont
créé la légende des remords d'athènes
légende selon laquelle il eût préféré du
philosophe aurait été fermées en signe
de deuil et les accusateurs condamné par
l'opinion publique
cette légende est une affabulation en
réalité les choses n'avaient pas changé
la mort de philosophes les avait
peut-être même empirer les idées de ce
cra tu déranges est encore immédiatement
après le décès les disciples fui la cité
parfait dans ce bâton part à mes gars à
50 kilomètres d'athènes où il rejoint
son ami euclide quitte mes gars et ils
parlent de leur maître qui viennent de
perdre
apparemment c'est à cette époque que
platon renonce définitivement à écrire
de la poésie de la tragédie et que le
projet d'offrir une postérité à socrate
mûri temps il a renoncé à tout produit
il est devenu son disciple qu'il a fui
avec les autres et maintenant il veut le
faire passer à la postérité
alors qu'il était absent lui seul savait
la véritable raison mais on peut en
imaginer deux il a peut être craint unis
qui tenait tant sa réputation de sagesse
de ne pas pouvoir maîtriser ses émotions
en assistant à la mort m type delattre
de fondre en pleurs comme un vulgaire à
tenir l'autre raison possible c'est
qu'il se sentait menacée politiquement
et qu'il n'avait pas envie d'être le
prochain menacé d'une peine de mort mais
les autres étaient là veut lui a manqué
de courage il le sait il culpabilise et
donc il veut se racheter
c'est lui le grand absent de la mort de
socrate qui va le rendre immortel c'est
aussi probablement le poids de son
infidélité final qui le rendra un fidèle
à la vérité historique qui le poussera à
transmettre de son maître une image
magnifier des discours ans retravaillé
et une réputation quasi blanche
platon a abandonné son destin politique
pour socrate il abandonne maintenant son
destin artistique pour se racheter
une fidélité les 28 écrits de platon
incarneront le zénith de la philosophie
sa pensée dominera le monde antique et
toute la philosophie occidentale il
forgera beaucoup des concepts et des
termes qui seront utilisés dans toute
l'histoire de la philosophie
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et il fera de ce 4
lesage rien écrit une légende
le père de la philosophie alors est ce
qu'on peut dire que la philosophie telle
qu'on la connaît né du regret de plateau
c'est bien possible
il a suffit d'un rien il devait être là
et s'il avait été là
[Musique]
à
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu'au
bout j'espère vraiment qu'elle vous a
donné une autre image de ce crash
et puis aussi une autre image de la
philosophie une image moins théorique
est plus vivante
derrière les idées il y à des hommes et
personnellement j'aime m'intéresser aux
hommes pour accéder aux idées et pour
mieux les comprendre
si cette vidéo vous a plu donnez lui un
pouce bleus et puis dites moi dans les
commentaires quels sont les philosophes
dont vous aimeriez découvrir la vie
j'ai déjà prévu de faire une vidéo sur
celle de platon donc n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner pour être prévenu quand
elle sortira je vous propose aussi de
télécharger ma synthèse des 100
meilleures idées philosophiques que vous
soyez étudiant ou pas c'est un moyen
efficace de découvrir facilement ou de
revoir rapidement les idées majeures de
l'histoire de la pensée sur celle de
secrets pour tout savoir de la vie de
socrate y compris plein d'anecdotes qui
ne sont pas dans cette vidéo je vous
recommande la lecture de l'article
socrates comme vous ne connaissez pas
dont le lien est dans la description
vous y trouverez aussi toutes mes
synthèse sur les idées de socrate ainsi
que mes sources je suis romain je suis
avec mon fidèle aristote qui méritera
lui aussi ou de graphie et vous étiez
sur mille idées de culture générale vous
n'avez pas besoin de culpabiliser comme
platon pour vous intéresser au meilleur
de la pensée sans vous prendre la tête
[Musique]
à